welcome to the recruitment rollercoaster
podcast my name's Hisham azuz today I'm
joined by someone you should all know
and her name is Rhonda D'Ambrosio she is
a transformation director for ebin Abel
and also the founder of mental health in
recruitment wonder is on a mission to
drive positive change to the
understanding of mental health issues in
order to improve lives improve business
within the recruitment industry and you
should all know who Ron there is she's
been involved in the live podcast events
we also sat down on episode 69 and a
while ago so hopefully you should know
who Ron there is if you don't know her
backstory we'll touch on it today but if
you don't feel free to go back to
episode 69 and also and you might have
seen that she's recently announced and
launched mental health on recruitment
which is what we're going to talk about
today and have a have a focus on so
Rhonda always a pleasure to chat to you
how are you yeah I'm good thanks so much
for having me back back on I know you're
one of my favorites but cool so what why
don't we why don't I just let you sort
of T this up then and sort of just give
a bit of a background for people that
may not know who you are and your story
and then sort of we can see that up into
sort of men's hair from cream and why
that exists let's start there okay no
problem so for those that don't know me
I'm wrong dude ambrósio I've been in the
recruitment industry since 1997
I've worked various jobs I would say
probably all level of roles in the
industry from running my own recruitment
business to running owns businesses and
in 2013 I diversified my recruitment
organization and after an episode a
situation involving my mum which we
talked about in the last podcast my mom
got diagnosed with motor neurone disease
and which took her life but it was her
mental resilience during that time that
inspired me to learn much more about
quality of thinking flexibility of
thinking and how when we choose our
responses to our emotions we can
positively impact our own mental health
and Men
to well-being so you know I kind of from
2013 onwards have been talking about
mental health in the industry and this
gained some momentum in 2017 after a
good friend and colleague of mine took
his own life and I guess the last three
years have led me to this point I'm at
today which is the launch of mental
health in recruitment yeah so really
driven by its interest in my whenever
I've spoken to people around mental
health and these things there's always
typically tip like really important
parts of their life and typically not so
good parts right losing losing your mom
was in what she's going through losing a
friend that sort of really sort of puts
foreign people's belly to make change or
change themselves whatever so that's
that's interesting so driven by things
that happen to you real purpose I guess
what what actually let's just start
there mentor from recruitment right says
well it is in the name Bert like why why
have you decided to launch mentor from
equipment do you know what it's a it's a
brilliant question and when I talk about
all the time I guess over the last
however many years and and however many
talks I've given how many times I've
stood up and addressed a roomful of
recruitment business owners or leaders
there seemed to be a common theme that
kept coming out and it was this lack of
understanding as to what mental health
actually was and this distinct disparity
between physical health and mental
well-being and you know I get that we're
a very resilient industry and we hire
people that are able to bounce back this
is part of our hiring frameworks these
are part of our competency frameworks
but the reality was that you know when
you looked at the stats within mental
health and you looked at the common
mental health disorders that we are we
know that are out there such as stress
anxiety and depression there seemed to
be this lack of understanding and
education as to what that looked like
you know so many recruitment businesses
felt that wasn't them that's not our
organization you know I feel great
everyone's good and you know and there
was this underlying assumption as well
that you know the successful people were
all good everyone's happy then you know
they make
money and the you know if you did
perhaps still with stress or you did
have some issues that didn't make you
capable so there was this paradox of
this is what I was seeing on a
day-to-day basis there was this paradox
of very much a lie around businesses
that felt they only hide the most
resilient people and therefore they had
this really strong work force and mental
health didn't impact them and then you
had this you know that probably the same
individuals that we're dealing with
their mental health and we're having to
do it you know beneath the surface and
you know that this is a lot of where the
Titanic thinking methodology came along
which as you may or may not remember
it's a coaching practice a self-help or
a leadership coaching method that really
helps individuals dig under the surface
as to you know what they're dealing with
on an everyday basis so I think it was
this complete and utter polar opposite
view whereby well you know we we cannot
be the exception to the stats now you
have all of these and this information
that's out there you've got the thriving
at work report that was published in
2017 and you've got this all of this
information all of this analysis by
Deloitte and and I was like are we
really staying that it doesn't impact us
and then hand-in-hand with that I would
have the same business owners come up to
me after the end of the talk I'm a given
and they would say to me do you know
what I don't know what I would do if an
employee came to me and told me they
were stressed yeah so you know typically
I guess I was talking to you know SMEs
if I didn't talk to larger businesses
then they would always advocate for the
fact they had an EAP an Employee
Assistance Program and yes they did this
and they did all these different
initiatives but what I found was you
know I was most in demand in a mental
health awareness week
or when there was something in the
calendar that would suggest we needed to
talk about mental health and you know I
think that if I really get to that you
know that the crux of it that was it for
me you know we weren't doing this enough
and we weren't doing this on a
consistent basis so you know a number of
these organizations were definitely
claimed to be people first
it was all are you people first or are
you trying to put a tick in a box now
how can we really drive this change if
we're kind of going against this this
tide and this understanding so and you
know the idea for mental health and
recruitment was very much born out of
you know creating the awareness creating
the education in order to drive the
positive action and the change and I
think that stemmed from all of the
different work mental health awareness
events or days that I did where I then
may not hear from a business it's like
you know God when can we talk about
action what are you doing to drive this
as action you know and are you doing it
from the very top of the organization or
is this just something that you're doing
to fill up the calendar yeah because
because I think that's it isn't I think
I think sometimes I don't know just from
what I consume online and the content I
consume sometimes I feel like it can be
perceived as sort of people talking
about mental health can sort of put the
blame on companies that they're not
doing anything about it and all these
things but I think really in reality
which is what you just shared there the
education piece and all these things is
actually how many business leaders and
how many business owners are equipped
with the know-how and the the sort of
experience and knowledge of how to deal
with people that have mental health
challenges and hardships right so I
think that's the first thing that I
think is really important to make clear
is that this isn't you trying to say
recruitment businesses only care about
mental health for a week in the year
it's look like what was clearly why
you've built this and why you've
actually created a vehicle is to
actually help educate these people which
is clearly what they needed to give them
a better chance of dealing with this
right because I think that's the main
thing isn't it's that this isn't
companies don't care I'm sure these
business leaders do care but have no
idea where to start wouldn't know what
to do if a lot of their staff came to
them and I think I think that's probably
really ever done during the coronavirus
and the conversations that I'm having
because you're having way more from the
conversations that I'm having there's
way more recruiters on the market
because they haven't been pleased with
how their business they've acted they
how to communicate with them all these
different things and then you've had
businesses that
what their culture I know what they're
about that has meant that they've
managed to get more people but also
meant that their people actually fried
than these things I think that's the
thing is the education and the know-how
so and how do you think we can actually
move the neither one men's health and
McCrimmon and is it but on the bottom up
change is there is it from the top down
is it both like how we're how can you
not I mean where where do you think
where does the change need to happen do
you think so
you know be out-of-the-box answer I
would probably says it has to come from
the top you need you know you do need to
have the senior stakeholders involved
with regard to changing any type of you
know organizational culture but I guess
with mental health and recruitment I'm
trying to cover it from all angles so
you know what you've got if it's for
those that haven't checked out you've
got the people element where you know
that as a collection of individuals that
are in the recruitment industry that put
in a stake in the ground and saying we
care about this message and we want to
create noise and get more of out there
we have got the podcast which is aimed
at speaking to people that have or have
suffered with their own mental health
and you know by putting those stories
out and by sharing those stories and
some of them are you know we cut quite
close to the bone but that creates the
awareness and that normalizes the
conversation and that encourages more
and more people to speak up and speak
out which inspires again there's a it's
like a you say it's like a chemical
reaction and you know so it's giving the
community the the people within the
industry that may suffer with a with a
voice but also we've got the showcase
element and the showcase part which
we're going to be launching [ __ ] is soon
is a place where recruitment businesses
that do do this well recruitment
business owners that have been doing
this for some time and do support mental
health for their people can really show
what they're doing because that will
inspire their peers to go okay right
brilliant what have you done and how
have you done it and that kind of ties
into you know the thing I'm most proud
of that we've talked about and that's
the awareness to action pledge and the
awareness to action pledge you know it
is aspired to a degree by the time to
change employers pledge I don't know if
you're familiar with that no no I don't
use give context
on that because I wasn't aware of that
when you tell me about this yes the time
to change employers page was kind of
very much about trying to drive
workplace and different corporate
organizations to support mental health
and to change and it was built very much
on the core principles and standards
that came out of the thriving at work
report and yet the thing with time to
change is that it's not industry
specific and it doesn't have to be but
they've also retired it it's been a
retired pledge so it gave people a good
framework it's brilliant resource and
I'd highly recommend anybody checks it
out but you know for me I thought wow in
recruitment I always joke that we kind
of like shortcuts we like things
simplified we're so busy and recruit and
business leaders just kind of like what
do I need to do how do I do it so the
awareness to action pledge was about
going out to the market and saying okay
are you committed to supporting mental
health and the mental health of your
employees and if you're committed you
know would you look at a roadmap to
enable you to get some organizational
change literally up and running the idea
is that if an organization signs up to
that they're sort of saying yeah we care
about this we're signing it we're
putting our name there and we're making
this very public declaration that we are
going to drive forward as a company to
look after and to recognize the
importance of this in the workplace but
the the roadmap element then helps and
supports them and gives them some action
so it's not like it's not a strict set
of rules but like we said earlier and
you said it gives them a little bit
where do we start
yeah we're not over complicating it you
know I'm not saying that all recruitment
owners business leaders HR directors
should make it complicated but sometimes
something is better than nothing and you
know actually when you baseline what
some organizations are doing they are
running initiatives they'll do stuff on
the different days they've do stuff all
year long but what they might not have
done is pulled that together in one
well-being or wellness strategy so of
course they're not been communicating
and talking about their workers strategy
and perhaps it's not being dressed at
board level which is where it needs to
be so really this is just something that
is you know if we can get recruitment
businesses or recruitment business
leaders to commit to do
publicly to sign up to working through
the roadmap and they are gonna be in
better shape than they were in
previously and that's where we gain
momentum and for me we truly how long
how long is the roadmap and well it's
broken down into six components some of
it does reflect the core standards of
the private work as well but we're going
to simplify it it's not gone out just
yet because we're just making some final
tweaks to it and the aim is that it's
going to be something that people want
to engage in and they know that if
they've got a stakeholder within the
business that can drive it it will be
quite straightforward so that's the one
thing that's happening in the background
I know a lot of people have said to me
it's been two weeks since launch what's
going on own because I wasn't
anticipating the response that we've had
and I don't mean that in a bad way
you know I would have no I wasn't
thinking it would go out with a bang but
I've genuinely been overwhelmed with the
amount of messages the amount of people
that want to get involved organizations
that want to support organizations
outside of the industry that want to
collaborate and there's just some
phenomenal conversations happening right
now whereby you think that this could
really help individuals this could
really really support the community and
you know Chris O'Connell one of the
ambassadors who you spoke to on the
podcast the other week you know he said
to me last week you know should we be
just looking at recruitment you know
shouldn't we be going out no this is a
big thing everyone should be doing it
he's really passionate about mental
health and I might you know what
absolutely but we're the people that are
involved at this had the greatest impact
its recruitment you know and you know I
like I was laughing you're saying you
know you don't you know who Rhonda is
you know I don't think for one minute
I'm a celebrity no I'm good people still
don't know me you on yeah exactly
there's a lot of people that don't know
who I am there's a lot of people that
won't know who Natasha Clark is despite
her being the ex-chief of people 4s3 you
know people that are involved you know
are known to some degree within the
industry and it's that in my opinion
that demonstrates we can we can have
significant impacts and we can make
change you know at the moment if we went
out to the hole with corporate world
with our messaging we're kind of playing
in a really really big big pond
less that I would encourage you staying
less sort of recruitment out first
exactly I'm also changing the world but
for me yeah you know I the reason
recruitments important to me is because
you know as an industry there is a I'm
not I don't know what the demographics
but is between men and women but what I
do know is that we are all under
pressure and we all are impacted by the
way in which the recruitment industry
drives and pushes forward whether it's
kpi's the way in which we're marinate
managed or among other things well why
do know is that men's mental health
rates are obviously far higher than
women's and as if I consider the
conversations I've been having for the
podcast you know we don't share so many
men are still afraid to talk about this
and still afraid to be vulnerable and I
think you know that's where you look at
the industry and for me I I'm talking to
some really larger-than-life characters
that I'm sure to everybody else that
like they're fine they're strong they've
got it sorted they're okay but the
reality is behind the scenes under the
surface and if these guys are dealing
with some some awful stuff I think yeah
I think I'd be confident I mean it's the
majority male that listen to this
podcast and I think you can probably you
can have a confident guess that there's
definitely more men in the recruitment
industry than there are women and I
think that's a really good point that
you highlight there which is why I've
tried to get some some males on here
including Chris just because I think as
well if you look at the people that are
really trying to drive this change it is
typically female led as well right it's
yourself it's Katie may [ __ ] it's
Michelle Flynn or they'd so I think that
that's a really good point so just two
things I know I know okay we're not
gonna hold you to this but I think just
to sort of wrap up the context so that
roadmap then and we looking at like a
12-month minimum 12-month roadmap or
what like just roughly just just to fill
in that context of I know you're
building it in these things but if I was
a business owner listen to this now
while I'm a recruiter none want to tell
my boss about it yeah is it is it like
here is that what we're talking here
laughter to a roadmap like twelve months
plus yeah I think the roadmap will give
people the direction
yeah and give them a signpost of kind of
right these are things that you need to
look at you need to address you need to
build in but there also needs to be a
level of not measurement but whereby we
check back and we are constantly
communicating with an organization as to
what they're doing how it's impacted
what the ROI has been what the feedback
has been from the team from the staff
and so on so I think it's like it's like
there's a there's a maintenance period
and I kind of this ties in to where
mental health and recruitment may go in
terms of a medium term longer term
strategy and how we can impact going
forward and but it is very much a case
of yet you have to be seen to be doing
these things and demonstrating that
you're doing it and then sharing your
story back to the industry to sort of
demonstrate these things make a
difference and to inspire other people
to do it you know there is no cost for
anyone to do this to do the awareness to
action page you know you and I know you
know every single element of Men's - of
treatment I've done myself I built
myself I've had no support I've had no
sponsorship that's not me getting my
small violin out so you know we can all
feel sorry for me but that's to say that
you know this is to me a fundamental
topic that should be being covered in
the industry and you know I get it it's
hard to for businesses to maybe put
their money where their mouth is and so
this isn't about trying to create a
revenue stream this is about trying to
drive change and you know who knows
where we will go with it and what we
will do I'd love to be adding more value
and loves when we get maybe 12 to 24
months in and we've got a certain number
of businesses that have signed the
pledge that have completed the roadmap
that are able to demonstrate the
journeyman on yeah then we'll look at
what else we can do and how we can
expand that because the amount of people
that want to get involved with this has
been phenomenal yeah you know again
let's do it maybe we just needed that we
needed somebody to create a vehicle and
say look here it is yeah I love that
vacation action mughelli I think it's
great I think the pledge makes complete
sense it's works in other industries and
will equip business owners on
on the know-how and the plan but also
there'll be a bit of accountability
there in these things which will help
them visualize and see the impacts which
is important and then also inspire
others to go wow that business is doing
that this visit those things right so
and what the other thing I wanted to ask
when he was talking was and so covered
off the the place of roadmap was why do
you think is why Dave I know you said
it's been overwhelming the amount of
people reached out on these things but
like why do you think it's been received
like that why do you think that so many
people have sort of reached out and I
know you said that I agree I'm sure I'm
sure he's confident that this would
resonate with people but why do you
think it's sort of really cut through
the noise and resonated with a lot of
people and why do you think there's been
a huge sort of uptake in interest and I
think timing has been everything and I
would say that the fact we've been in
lockdown the fact that we're in the
middle of a pandemic and it is impacted
every single person out there has made a
massive difference and there will be
individuals the types of which I've
referred to earlier on the individuals
that maybe just didn't get it
that didn't see mental health as a thing
or you know who have maybe strolled
these are certainly the conversations
that I've been having individuals that
have had mental strengths have struggled
in knock down you know discuss that has
been come and I think it was the mind
report that talks about people that have
never had them before I think it was
something like 25% now saying they they
have that's they felt a mental health
issue or anxiety or some stress or
whatever it was yeah drew a lockdown and
you know there's some there is some
great research that's sort of out there
at the moment and you see a university
college london or doing this sort of
ongoing covert social study so i think
you know that puts it on everybody's
radar
you know I've certainly been the busiest
that I've probably ever been in this
space in the last three months you know
I've talked a lot about how to combat
feelings of stress and anxiety and
overwhelm in in the situation that we've
been in
and I think that's probably what's
touched you know people get it and don't
get me wrong you know at the beginning i
if you know if you look at the mental
health and recruitment instagram page
which is only it's not even three months
old the reason that I kind of pushed the
button on that and crazy that when when
I did was because I was also seeing the
same posts of people that want to talk
about mental health because we're in a
pandemic and the frustration for me was
like well hold on a minute you know I've
been trying to talk about this and I'm
great brilliant wit we're talking about
it but by first my Instagram was you
know mental health is for life not just
coronavirus so you know it's brilliant
that we've created a bit more awareness
it's brilliant that more leaders are
kind of thinking oh okay even I'm I'm
kind of not impenetrable when it comes
to these sorts of issues and but this is
an ongoing thing we all have physical
the same way we all have mental health
and you know some people are going to be
my mental health is probably better than
my physical health you know I don't I
don't go to the gym and work out like I
should but I work my mental agility my
flexibility of thinking constantly so
you know we are all different and it's
making sure that as employers we have a
duty of care to our people that covers
both of those different different sides
of the coin so and how so how do you
think this periods like what do you
think will stay
what like in terms of what how do you
think this period will have a lasting
impact on sort of the discussion and
topic of mental health as we come out of
this love what what do you hoping will
actually stick because as you quite
rightly said yeah there's way more
people talking about which is great but
I think is and you always hear this from
the people that are sort of really
trying to drive change throughout and
then you hear see and read these things
around after mental health week which is
mental awareness week is interest for a
week and all these things right so I get
it but I'd like to think there'll be
things that will stay and keep during
this period positive things but what
what you hope will stick and yeah the
big one for me is I'm hoping the empathy
will stick and I know what it's like to
be a leader
I know it's hard when you're trying to
you know juggle the needs of the
business with the needs of the people
but empathy is such a powerful tool and
such an important tool in leadership and
you know I think the empathy has come
from and been driven by the fact that
we've all been feeling what we've been
feeling maybe some of us have struggled
and not dealt with it as well as we
thought we might and its retaining that
it's understanding that crikey if I can
just remember how it felt in that
situation and take that into the
everyday life the workplace when we get
back to the new normal but actually know
it's important we look at this I think
that's the big thing for me I want the
empathy to stay and I also want the I
want the mindset the mindset shift to
say so you know I'm always talking about
growth mindset I'm always talking about
challenging yourself and not being bound
by you know this this level of well this
is the way it is this is the way it is
because it's the way it's always been
this is where is because this is the way
that you know I I've said it is and so
many business leaders in the last three
or four months and many maybe would have
never considered having their work force
work from home right well we don't do
that we cuz our culture so no that's
just not the way it and they've been
forced to come out of their comfort zone
they've been forced to lean into
discomfort and I think what they've seen
is it's positively impacted their people
it's definitely improved the
relationship that they've got with their
staff the transparency piece is
brilliant and it helps with trust and
our that's the stuff that that's what
drives good business and that's what I'd
like to see tap on as we come back to
the new normal yeah I like that so let's
so I think by this point we've covered a
lot of good things I think people
listening will know that talking about
meant elf is important that it's
something that we need to sort of do
more around particularly as an industry
but why don't me talk about some of the
challenges that people have of this
right as we were talking before because
I think this is really important all
about being open and honest on here so I
think that the FIR the first challenge
which I feel like could actually
translate into talking about it
internally but I think there really is
this sort of perception that it's it's
called to talk about mental health right
now right it's and I think that can
sometimes really prevent people to talk
about it even if they might their
intention
be true and genuine and authentic but I
think there is this or what's the word
since it's like cynical Ness to our
Rhonda just talking about them in 12
because yeah it's a good thing to talk
about in these things and I think that
can really prevent people talking about
it and be worried about talking about it
internally and also externally do you
think that somehow can we combat that do
you think because there's definitely
people out there that do it too yeah I
guess helps them with their brand and
all these things but I don't know how
can we change that do you think there's
I do think that stops people from
wanting to talk about it god I think
you're bang on there and that's probably
a topic for a whole lot of podcasts
there's an accountability piece within
it you know and I think that if somebody
wants to drive change if somebody wants
to get involved and whether it's a
business owner that's trying to get
their staff to talk about it you know
more people will always be fearful
they'll be fearful that it's fadi their
real question probably the reasons why a
leader that's paid no interest in this
previously now wants to encourage
talking and this is where role modeling
is absolutely vital you cannot expect
people to open up and be vulnerable to
you if you cannot open up and be
vulnerable to them and this is why a big
part of sort of driving any sort of
cultural change going back to the road
map and the awareness to action pledge
there has to be a senior stakeholder and
there has to be somebody that is sharing
themselves and is open to sharing and
you know the beginning of the year I
spoke to somebody in the industry and
very well-respected individual someone
who I respect very much and that person
said to me the problem you're going to
have funder getting individuals and
businesses talking about mental health
is the perception that if they support
and if they're talking and if they're
trying to drive change that maybe
they'll be viewed as having a mental
health issue themselves although there's
a problem in their business and I get
that but that's exactly the kind of
stigma that we need to kind of shift
from and so it shocks me that to some
degree that is that the case is there a
huge proportion of our industry that
we'll never talk about it because
they're scared of what people
oh I think that's probably right I think
there are you know pockets of
recruitment that are built on ego I
think there are pockets that really do
care about making sure that people are
looked after and what we need to do is
just evolve you know Revolver our sector
into the space whereby people are first
because you know if you are talking to
businesses and if you are talking to
your clients and your candidates about
being the right recruitment partner to
be using and you're talking about the
fact that you will put them first as a
customer or as a client and you kind of
got to be able to demonstrate that
you're doing that internally first of
course there's just a complete all
dentists attea bout your brand and your
product so and you know you've gotta
walk the walk yeah and and i think i
think for me how i sort sort of them can
relate to this is when I work recruiters
on helping them build their brand of
these things time and time again I I
sort of get the question of why he
should what what people think of me like
this or if I say this are people gonna
think I'm like this and my response
always which I feel like it's relevant
to this but it's a bit more complex is
that if you're if that's who you are
then that's how you're gonna be
perceived so if you are someone that is
using mental health as a vehicle to
elevate your brand sort of be perceived
in a good light and that's not true you
will get found out and that works the
same way is if you're opening up because
it's you know it's important then you
recognize that it has to start with you
and that's your intention and it's not
the latter then that also be seen do you
know I mean I think that that's how I
relate to is if you are generally being
honest and authentic and attention is
right then that that will be seen some
people may not see that straightaway but
I think over a period of time whether
okay yeah no yeah everyone there
definitely is
she means this the intentions right and
and I think the thing where so when
you're talking about that I think
especially in the recruitment world when
you say leaders have to leave by the
front and talking these things I think
sometimes people's minds go straight
away well does that mean that I have to
open up about
deepest darkest secrets does that mean
that I online I shown weakness by
talking about these things I just feel
like some people will as soon as you
start going look wonder you're the
leader of this business you need to
start talking and these types of things
I feel that straight away people's minds
come on the two of not sure about that
is it weakness is it sort of talking to
people about things that I shouldn't bid
you know I mean I think I think you're
really brilliant point and absolutely
vital there is a difference between
being a leader who's demonstrating and
role modeling that vulnerability is okay
and it's alright to talk about these
things and then forcing people to have
to do the same you know you have to
safeguard you have to make sure that
you're looking after your people and the
aim is that you're putting practices
support initiatives policy in place to
help them
you're not demanding that they share
your deepest darkest secret secrets
you're not demanding that they are being
vulnerable what you're trying to do and
what we're asking businesses to do is to
create a safe space for people to bring
them bring themselves and be their whole
selves and not have to hide that you
know not every day is maybe easing that
they can get through it and there was
there's all manner of ways in which you
can address this and it could be that
you know you own the business you're sat
and you're discussing this as part of
board as part of strategy and you're
going to impact or mend your sickness
absence policy Kishin and you're gonna
include mental health days in that so
you know I think talking about it is
about the leadership authenticity and
building trust you know you've heard me
talk about brain chemistry before and
the importance of building trust and
transparency in leadership and this is
what this is the benefit for people to
be able to do that because it's not
gonna happen overnight you know and and
I think you're right people often say to
me well we've got mental health first
aiders does that mean we're covered and
I almost feel like it's great that
you've got mental health first aiders
but first of all do you have the right
people as mental health first aiders
typically the very empathetic
individuals that want to get involved
and want to support will put themselves
out and say yes I'd like to be involved
but they're maybe not given the training
around how to set relevant boundaries
and how to manage these emotions and
quite often you can have individuals
that absorb some of these problems and
try to fix and they're not the right
people so there is something to be said
for sort of look and external strategies
and ways in which you can help your
people and that's kind of you know a
part of that you've seen the mental
health and recruitment one of our
collaborations is with need to chat then
can rights initiatives and you know that
isn't mental health support but that is
community based peer-to-peer support
where people can talk about things that
they're dealing with their day their
struggles without fear of judgment and
that's really important so you know I
think you're absolutely right it's not
about saying to people you have to
expose yourself and you have to share
but maybe what it is is is an individual
that sees a colleague talk about the
things they're struggling with and
almost resonates with them that okay I'm
not the only person in with that and
that in itself helps massively you know
if you look at some of Mines key
insights for I think it was 1718 it may
be the next one you know mind a talking
about the fact that it's proven to help
people it's proven to make people feel
better when they talk about issues that
they've got and they and they share what
it is that they're dealing with so kind
of I think yeah there's a whole I think
is a whole I think yeah you want that
very well so the the second the second
challenge then that I'm gonna now take
this to being in the leaders shoes and
some of the challenges or perceptions
that they may have because I've heard
this right so the other challenge that
I've heard which I think and be
interested to get your thoughts on is
for on the other side where as a leader
you've got an employee who you think is
potentially using their mental health
issues as a bit an excuse as you're then
questioning sort of the intention of or
the sincerity of runs ago and you know
what I'm really struggling he shambhala
blah and I'm your leader I think that's
really interesting challenging and a
hard thing to deal with as well because
then you've got leaders who may think
that but and then they're really worried
about having that in the wrong way there
their reputation or not wanting to make
things worse although but I think
there's a whole thing there which
I feel like can prevent leaders taking
action or getting involved whatever
because then sometimes I might have had
that experience where their guts like
you know what not I just don't know if
ROM has been truthful here and she's
telling me that she's really struggling
brother blood you're not me I don't know
if you've heard that but I've heard that
quite a lot of nothing that's that
that's also really hard as a leader to
judge that that's harder as well I think
I think you're right and I would say
that you know I'd certainly come across
what you're talking about myself as a
leader and you know on the other side
the other kind of the flip side of that
with regards to supporting our people
and knowing what to do is having the
right framework in place with regard to
your process and policies and
understanding the HR side of it
understanding what should be in place
and making sure that you know you know
what process you should be following
because again as so many businesses that
I'm talking to and have spoken to in the
last two years may outsource their HR
support so they won't necessarily know
that these are things we need to look at
this is how we have a conversation or
have a welfare meeting at this point
will refer to the sickness absence
policy at this point you know I guess
what I'm advocating for and the changes
that I'm looking to see are about
humanizing the way in which we deal with
our people but that doesn't mean that we
cannot have a robust HR practice and
policy in place you know and and I've
introduced I think into two different
businesses I've work with the Bradford
index and the Bradford index is
something that measures short-term
persistent absence you know and again if
it's used in the right way it's a
vehicle for conversation and you can
support and you can help people but
typically you know we don't look at that
do we you know you've just sort of
mentioned that maybe it's a girl
instinct a leader having a chat with
somebody you know and absolutely I would
never say to a recruitment business
leader oh yeah you know just give them
this amount of time off just give them
up you know be really supportive it's
not about the fluffy side of it it's
about running your business effectively
running your business in line with the
health and the executive the health and
safety executives wishes that you know
around your duty of care and kind of
doing it doing it the right way and
being human about it I think this comes
into the education piece again isn't
absolutely I think that's where
sometimes the frustration can be is like
you've got to the point where you've got
someone telling you that they find it
really difficult but you're not sure a
house and say that is you like you've
got something not sure but before all of
that even happened you've got no sort of
framework that you're talking about
you've got no process that could have
helped you prevent getting to this point
where you feeling that way so I think
you know that you're right I think that
ties in to leaders as you said have been
more educated and like having processes
in place that can help them with
situations like that
which starts with normalizing the
conversation about it all right yeah
it's having those conversations it's
knowing what the process is it snowing
for example that you know you can offer
to make reasonable adjustments to
support people it's knowing that if this
is an ongoing condition if it's been a
condition maybe for two years that then
that comes into the Disability
Discrimination Act there is it there is
so much information out there that I
don't think you look at because we're
kind of scared to go down the rabbit
hole and for god what could happen it
could be a nightmare yeah cool as we
come to the ends of this then let's
let's just talk about what's what have
you got on the I know you've been
working your absolute socks off but
what's on the sort of roadmap for men's
health and recruitment man so as you
said you launched a couple of weeks ago
people it's been received really well
got people that have really bought into
it what what some on the roadmap
what's on the agenda first and foremost
what we're looking at is almost roles
and expectations for the champions and
the ambassadors and that's stemmed from
the amount of interest that we've had
and the individuals that wants to be
involved so what we've decided is we
need to have a bit more of a framework
around that so that the people that are
getting involved kind of know what it
means to be a mentor accrue from a
champion and maybe tie in you know some
activities around that regarding the
pledge you know and this isn't something
I've talked to everybody about just yet
but kind of how I see this evolving is
this is a way that our champions can
make tangible difference out in the
industry outside of the roles we've been
got the awareness to action pledge that
needs to be launched we've got the
podcast which is obviously continuing so
constantly looking
for people to sort of talk to about that
and there are some conversations
happening at the moment some really
exciting conversations about I can't say
too much but collaborations some
well-known people in the industry and
some not so well-known people outside of
the industry but if that happens that
will be absolutely amazing because that
will drive the awareness of mental
health and improvement forward and it
will also potentially support our
community regarding their actual mental
health issues I don't mean to be cagey
but do this at the moment and you know
for those that don't know the other side
of it is that this isn't just a UK
initiative you know we are we're talking
to Australia we're talking to the u.s.
we're talking to New Zealand I've had
somebody contact me from South Africa
somebody else contact me from Belgium so
this is about providing and you know
change to the industry at a global level
so there's lots and lots and lots to do
and to all the people are saying you
know can we get involved what we can
walk and we do anyone's got any ideas
about what they could be doing to
support absolutely please contact us
love that thing is great what you're
doing runned honestly and so look part
in words then and if I'm listening right
now when I guess just parting words on
sort of if I'm someone that might be
having a tough time I'm someone that
doesn't feel like I've got any outlet in
the sort of circumstances and
recruitment business that I'm in and I
guess yeah what would your sort of
advice be to anyone that right now feels
like they would like to talk to someone
or is struggling or whatever just I
guess just important words around that I
guess I think talk to somebody that you
trust if you can in the first instance
you know it doesn't have to be somebody
in recruitment but maybe two or three
different people that you can have a
safe compensation with and you can tell
them how you're feeling and if genuinely
people the idea of doing that creates a
level of anxiety within itself you know
the Samaritans offer a free number you
can there there are multiple places that
you can speak to people and get support
and on the mental half in recruitment
and website what we have is a list
of mental health support resources for
number of different things they're not
generic ones they are whether it's men's
mental health whether it's eating
disorders whether it's you know all
sorts of stuff so maybe have a look but
but don't stop talking I think that's my
biggest piece of advice please don't
stop talking that wonder has been a
pleasure thank you thank you for having
me